dr amish adulja is with us now he's a
senior scholar at the johns hopkins
center for health security at the
bloomberg school of public health he's
joining us from
pittsburgh excuse me dr adelga let's
start with the efficacy
of this johnson and johnson vaccination
expected to be approved
later today how does it compare to the
others and then what does this mean for
our timeline of vaccinating people in
the country
well when you look at a vaccine you have
to decide what you want it to do and
what we want with these coveted vaccines
are to prevent serious illness
hospitalization and death and the
johnson and johnson vaccine stacks up
very well
against the moderna and pfizer vaccine
and has the added benefit that it's a
single dose so you get that protection
basically you're one and done pretty
quickly after you get that vaccine
and remember these were not studied head
to head in trials and the trials differ
between the modern vaccine the pfizer
vaccine and the johnson johnson vaccine
so i wouldn't compare the raw numbers
head-to-head and try to draw any
conclusions this is a great vaccine it's
going to be a huge addition to our menu
of vaccines and anybody that's offered
this vaccine should take it as soon as
it's available to them
doctor yesterday the cdc said the 10
percent of cases they believe
right now are now variants of this uk
variant that was detected
how are companies adjusting as this new
vaccine rolls out to the variants
that are coming out companies are being
very proactive and they're doing a
couple of things there are some
companies that are trying to decide
whether or not they can come up with a
modified version of the vaccine that
better matches these variants
and there are other companies that are
thinking about could we give a third
dose of the same vaccine
to boost your immunity even further but
remember we're not across that threshold
yet where we need to do something
specific about these variants i think
the threshold for me is if somebody gets
hospitalized it's a breakthrough
infection they've already been
vaccinated vaccinated but we're not
quite there yet and these vaccines do
very well against the variants
especially the uk variant when it comes
to what matters serious illness
hospitalization and death and i think we
have to keep returning to that that's
what we're trying to do
tame this virus defang it make it unable
to threaten hospital capacity again and
our vaccines are all very good against
all the variants when it comes to that
that end point as more and more people
get vaccinated i'm seeing it i'm seeing
this sort of euphoria
of people in the sense we're going to
get back to normal and sooner than we
may have expected
but you said in salon this week that you
believe there has been an
over emphasis on what you cannot do
once you're vaccinated can you elaborate
well when you see people talking about
the vaccine sometimes they'll say well
you have to go and basically nothing
changes and it's not true
things do change when you get vaccinated
you're basically protected from
symptomatic disease
you're very less likely to spread this
virus to somebody else
and if you're doing things for example
if you're going out and
maybe you're somebody that's an early
adopter of going to indoor dining you're
at very low risk of getting serious
infection
and when you're with another person
that's vaccinated you can basically do
anything
with that other vaccinated person
because of the because you're on the
same timeline because you're both
protected
and if you're seeing somebody that's
unvaccinated the risk to you is very
very low so i do think that this does
change
change your life and i think that people
are really often kind of underselling
the vaccine
saying well this doesn't do this this
doesn't do this and
i think what we're looking at are really
tremendous vaccines that are going to be
the path to normalcy
that the people should be optimistic
about them and if we don't tell people
that
that this vaccine is going to benefit
their life if it's going to improve
their life
they're not going to get the vaccine and
i think we have to really think about
how we're talking about this vaccine in
the media
quickly you you mentioned that that this
notion of covet
zero is a fantasy why
you have to remember that coronaviruses
are part of the viruses that cause the
common cold they cause about 25
of our common colds this virus spreads
like that it spreads efficiently through
the respiratory route it's established
itself in the human population
we will never get it down to zero the
goal as i said before
is to tame it so that it doesn't cause
severe illness does it so that it can't
hospitalize people or threaten hospital
capacity and we'll get there with the
vaccine
but this isn't going to be an irratible
disease or it's it's not going to be
eliminated we'll still have covet cases
five years from now but they're never
going to be able to threaten us the way
they can now
once we get people vaccinated we
certainly hope so
dr amish adulterer thank you